de londres a berlín pasando por parís un
mismo continente pero con políticas de
países muy diferentes frente al virus la
pandemia comenzó hace más de un año y
los parisinos sienten que se trata de
una historia sin fin desde el viernes la
ciudad es una de las 16 regiones
francesas confinadas por tercera vez
cuando va a terminar esto si en un año
no hemos encontrado una salida todo esto
para el próximo año acaso tendremos el
confinamiento número 8 las reglas de ese
nuevo confinamiento son complejas no
siempre claras y los franceses afectados
deben tener un certificado si salen a
más de 10 kilómetros de su casa o si
salen después de las 7 de la noche todo
esto mientras la campaña de vacunación
sigue estando frenada pero en el reino
unido- la estrategia es radicalmente
diferente después de haber vivido un
confinamiento severo en enero el país
está aliviando las restricciones y los
bares deberían poder reabrir a mediados
de abril abrimos las reservas a partir
del 12 de abril y ya estamos llenos para
esa primera semana así que parece que
vamos a estar
desde hace varios meses el gobierno
británico lo ha apostado todo a la
vacunación este sábado la mitad de la
población adulta es decir casi 27
millones de personas ya habían recibido
una primera dosis de la vacuna alemania
por otra parte parece lejos de estar
fuera de peligro desde hace tres semanas
el número de casos se ha disparado a
pesar de varios semi confinamientos
impuestos desde finales de diciembre
fatalista el ministro de sanidad alemán
declaró el viernes que según él no
existen suficientes vacunas para detener
el avance de la tercera ola en europa